when I study for my Series 7 I studied  for my Series 7 every day next to my  grandmother's plot at Forest Lawn right  after 170 134 freeway I don't know if  you guys know where that's at and I  would sit right next to her and I would  read my Capital book to take my series  seven because she had just died so I  would study there it was calming for me  when I would take a break I would walk  and this was my exercise  yeah I don't recognize that name  nope  39 years this person lived  62 years  83 years  49 years and you would stand like this  who is this guy  and then there was like one big one you  see this name and he'd go Google it oh  wow this guy was somebody  okay crazy boom  and I would sit down and say okay when  the day comes and you die what are you  going to say when they walk by your plot  here lies a short-term thinker hell to  the no